nigel i mean what seems here on wembley
way it is an incredibly good atmosphere
how excited are you about today i mean
incredibly excited i mean you're
absolutely right i mean you've got a
fantastic view here as well um and it's
great to see the mix you know there's a
lot more women a lot more young people i
think we've had a hundred thousand
children attend these record-breaking
events already and today is going to be
the icing on the cake the magic number
to beat is 79 115 yes that's the biggest
uh um euros uh event ever men's all
women's and i think we might even do
that today so another record well do you
know what i think it's impossible to get
a ticket around here even some
ex-england players who've been around me
today have not got tickets and they're
all trying to get a ticket by hooker by
crook and you can't you can't get one
what's impressed you most about this
this england squad um because i've loved
the way
they've smiled and they've they've gone
through all these victories and they've
scored a lot of goals but they have
smiled and enjoyed the entire thing and
as a sports minister that's got to be
what you want to see well absolutely and
they take their responsibilities as well
really seriously in terms of inspiring
that future generation and talking
positively about each other and you just
see it on the field as well they're a
real team you know the way that they
pass and so on i always promised my team
by the way a sports minister i'd never
get into punditry but you just see that
teamwork in a way that you don't always
see with the men's game and but i say
this this inspiration the long-term
impact of the success we've had here we
shouldn't underestimate it i mean this
is the biggest women's sporting event in
european history right here on our soil
and thank you to you as well because
it's getting the mainstream needle it's
getting
a lot more women excited not just didn't
play in the game but on all the other
aspects of women in sport so huge thank
you to you oh you're very welcome
we haven't done anything apart from tell
a really great story there's been some
very young girls um along this road
today with their dads with their moms
some of them have been to the
semi-finals
this is on your watch so what are you
going to do about it are you going to
make football compulsory in schools for
girls
shouldn't be just netball it shouldn't
be just hockey
make football as part of the rotation in
pe are you going to do that i'm really
keen actually i think the key thing is
we need to make sure that everybody has
a sport that they can enjoy at school
now for a lot of people that will be
football and there's been huge progress
with women's football and football at
schools over the last few years but i
think it's only about 65
of schools currently uh have gains for
girls so i'd like to see more of that
but also to be honest i'd like to see a
whole range of other sports as well
because not everybody hard hard for us
to believe not everybody's necessarily a
football fan but we are working on more
diversity
of sports in schools and also of course
grassroots getting more grassroots
facilities and we're investing in that
as well so yes it's what's in school but
also what happens out of school and
exploiting those school facilities to
the fullest extent because they're
locked behind closed doors way too much
of the time so we're opening them up as
well and how immediately are you going
to sort of get to work on the legacy
because you know it's already happening
we've missed opportunities in the past
and this is such an incredible moment
for women's sport whatever happens
tonight there is already an incredible
legacy because i say there will be uh
you know kids today uh coming to this
event who are going to be the sports
stars of the future because they've been
inspired there is already a legacy there
but coming off uh you know pretty
difficult two years with activity levels
going down during the pandemic we need
to get activity levels going up again
having events like this getting uh young
people in particular excited about sport
again is absolutely key there is already
going to be a legacy plus we put on this
major event all the economic benefits
that brings we are getting a fantastic
reputation in the uk of putting on major
events and in particular women's events
and that will have a long lasting impact
as well and you must be delighted to see
the sort of crowd you've got here today
because i was here just over a year ago
for the men's euros it was a very very
different atmosphere to what we've got
today i much prefer this one if i'm
honest well to be honest so do i and
actually it's one of the things i've
seen as well i've been for three of the
three of the games and every single one
of them the atmosphere has been amazing
and i get reports as you can imagine
after each event about what incidents
are taking place and sometimes i get nil
reports or virtually no disturbances you
know so i think it shows that we
if we all behave we can all enjoy a lot
more
[Music]
and what are we going to do about
inclusivity because that has been
something that has popped up time and
time again for these euros is that
football needs to be more inclusive we
need to see more asian girls playing
football we need to see
more black girls playing football and
therefore it must be
accessible in terms of being cheap and
people must be able to take their kids
without it costing them any money
especially in the times we're living in
and what can we do about that that goes
to that facility's point that we talked
about and i say just simple things like
opening up school facilities because too
much of it is a lot behind school gates
and not used is key but we're also
investing 230 million
in multi-sport facilities right across
the country but particularly targeting
those areas of the country that don't
currently have great facilities so that
will
particularly impact the very groups that
you just mentioned because they are
currently the ones who are deprived of
sporting facilities and we're out of
time but
give us a prediction today i mean you're
quite excited i can't i'm very excited i
know i'm buzzing of course we've got the
commonwealth games going on as well so
i'm doubly buzzing um i don't know i
just i just want one more than the other
guys
that's all that matters one more than
germany
you're not going to predict
you know maybe two one would be good but
i don't care as long as it's one more as
long as that as long as it's one more
bet me gets the golden boot that'd be
good okay good you didn't sit on the
fence